Aww Yeah!
Today we're learning English with Inside Out!
I'm Andrea, and before we get into
today's lesson, I want to let you know
that every week here on learn English
with TV series, we make lessons just like this one,
to help you learn fast English
without getting lost, without missing the jokes,
jokes and without subtitles.
In fact, Camila says that our channel has
taken her vocabulary
and comprehension to a new level.
So if you want to achieve your
next level in your English learning
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and the bell down below
so that you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Do you want to master how natives really speak?
Then I highly recommend our Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48-week course, you will learn with
the first two seasons of Friends.
You'll receive PDF Power Lessons every week,
vocabulary memorization software ,
access to our Fluency Circle
global community, and so much more.
And did you know that you could try it
right now for FREE with our 3-part masterclass?
All you have to do is click up here
or in the description box below,
to learn more and sign up now.
We hope to see you there!
Do you want to learn more English
expressions and vocabulary?
Then why not check out our lesson on Pixar's
first animated movie Toy Story?
You can click up here or, in the description box
below to watch it straight after this lesson.